some contact lens brands say that it's
okay to sleep in them but as a general
rule it's really not my name is dr.
Irina bilinski I am an eye surgeon
specializing in oculoplastic sand ocular
oncology contact lenses are safe but
they're safe if you take care of them
appropriately and part of good contact
lens hygiene is not sleeping in your
contact lenses think of the contact
lenses foreign material in your eye it's
sort of like a sponge and to be
comfortable the contact lens needs to be
moist so it absorbs moisture from your
eye and it can also trap bacteria and so
it's very important to take your contact
lenses out to clean them periodically
leaving them in when you sleep can cause
an eye infection that can sometimes be
really really bad
a lot of the infections can be mild and
go away with antibiotic eyedrops but
some infections can be really really
severe and even if they go away they can
cause scarring of the surface of your
eye which is the cornea and that scar
can cause sort of a permanent change in
your vision sometimes an infection can
be devastating and it can completely
cause the eye too scarred to the point
that someone might need a corneal
transplant or lose vision completely
really serious blinding kind of
infections related to contact lens wear
are rare fortunately if they were common
then nobody would ever wear contact
lenses so they are exceedingly rare and
they usually have to do with really
really bad contact lens I gene so good
contact lens hygiene has to do with a
few things one knowing if your contact
lens needs to be changed
every month or every two weeks and
trying to stick to that even if you have
to put a reminder in your calendar the
more common thing that we see is just
contact lens over where the cornea gets
devoid of oxygen so a contact lens does
start to break down over time so it
doesn't have a smooth surface it's gonna
form micro breakdown kind of edges and
the contact lens will also dry out I
mean your eye just doesn't have enough
moisture to keep a contact
in there forever you think of the
contact lens as a sponge like the sponge
in your kitchen you have to clean it
every so often you might even have to
replace it every so often because it
just doesn't do the job right anymore
a contact lens can become kind of folded
and entrapped in the eye underneath of
the lid so I have seen that where
patients come in with chronic red eye
and you look around very carefully and
sometimes and this is also rare but you
can actually extract a contact lens that
has probably been there for months it
can happen if you put it in wrong it can
happen if you sleep in it it can happen
if you don't take it out or if you
forget to take it out take your contact
lenses out don't leave them in take them
out every day